今天分享的课程内容是不同风格的曲风之
词义方向
这个就像电影一样
今天是拍动作片
那动作片跟恐怖片他连色温都不一样
影片的色温都不一样
然后配乐也不一样
就像今天的课程一样
不同的曲风本来就要配上不同的词义
方向好
那我们今天遵循一个传统
就是念一首韵脚诗
这首韵脚诗叫还爱你
就稍微悲伤了一点点
还爱你
不是付出不够多
而是不公平
而是你的微笑始终不透明
逐渐膨胀
累积的阴影被削减成一句句无情
像箭矢般不停不停在伤害爱情
亲爱的
那些带着血恶狠狠射穿你的声音
都先穿过我的心
今天分享的这首韵脚诗稍微悲情了一点点
这个就是韵脚诗的魅力文字
魅力文字会让你有画面感
有想象
然后你的情绪会投入
所以同学们记得除了歌词创作之外
闲暇时语不妨也练习看看韵脚词的创作
今天分享的曲风有三大类
一个是摇滚的
一个是IMB的
一个是中国风
这首歌是多年前的创作
叫千年之恋
千年之恋其实是男女对唱的歌
那当初就是先有曲
那快板的歌或者是偏摇滚的歌
你的词要有些爆裂的感觉
就是愤怒的感觉
特别是他还有某种程度的中国风的韵味
它的潜质用语就很特别
他的旋律是摇滚
但是它的词义的画面感是偏中国风的
那接下来就稍微介绍一下谁在悬崖沏一壶茶
温热前世的牵挂
你看牵挂这个词汇一出来
那他就是中国风了
所以我说中国风是创作的概念跟方向
他不是音乐定义上的曲风类型
它只要某个领域符合了
它就是广义的中国风
好第二行
而我在调整千年的时差
爱恨全喝下千年的时差
千年画面感够强了
所以这样子的一个调性的音乐
你去弄个反差的歌词
所有的反差是一般摇滚不会想到中国风
但是摇滚把中国风录取了
哎呦反而有点反差或者是颠覆的敏感
这个是创作上的一个尝试
就说未来如果你没有机会有个partner
他是负责作曲的
可能不擅长文字
那他又喜欢写摇滚
那恭喜你
就有个很特殊的作品出现
因为摇滚的曲风配上中国风韵味的词汇
那是很迷人的一种结
现在分享的是第二段岁月
在岩石上敲打
我又留长了头发
耐心的等海岸线的变化
大雨就要下
我为什么当初写大雨就要下
因为后面的歌词是风狠狠的刮
谁在害怕谁是设问吗
因为前面写大雨就要下
这样的歌词经营是很迷人的
副歌的第一行是海风
一直眷恋着沙
你却错过我的年华
这里的你跟我就是对战
海风跟沙这样子的语法结构
他中国风的调性很浓稠
所以呢你去入职的时候
一方面经营画面感
一方面用修辞学去寻找对仗或夸饰
或是譬喻
无形中你这首中国风的歌词
创作就会变成一种经典
所以经典是建立在努力上
技术上
技术一定要加上努力
那我今天教的都是技术
那努力就要靠你们自己了
继续压制副歌
第二大段
蝴蝶依旧狂恋着花
你却错过我的年华
同学们有没有注意到
副歌的记忆点居然在第二句
海风一直眷恋着沙
蝴蝶依旧狂恋着花
这个词汇是有换的
有更替的
但是第二句没有
你却错过我的年华
重点是放在你却错过我的年华
所以这个副歌的基点没有换
而且是放在第二句这里
就说明我一再一再强调的变化
接下来的歌词是错过我转世的脸颊
你还爱我吗
我等你一句话
这里面有个重复的字句哦
就是你却错过我的年华
错过我转世的脸颊
歌词的用语是很适合这样子的
重复性的使用
重复性的出现会增强记忆点
因为通常我创作歌词的时候
跟各位同学分享这首歌比较有感觉
想法比较多
他重复唱的时候
会重写哦
有时候你看到一些流行音乐
他重复唱的时候
副歌唱完又回到主歌的时候
歌词意境一样也没有不行
就说有些歌适合从头到尾的歌词就只有四遍
M a two b one b two
有些歌是适合A2A2的时候重新填写
然后副歌保留
有些是连副歌都有变化
但是第一行保留
这个都是被录取的
而且是不同的创作形式
一生行走
望断天涯
最远不过是晚霞
而你今生又在哪户人家欲语泪先下
沙滩上消失的浪花
让我慢慢想起家
曾经许下的永远又在哪
总是放不下轮回的记忆
在风化
我将它牢牢地记下
前面酝酿的画面感
提供后面情绪的空间
他可以爆发
就是你又错过我的年华
是情绪的最高点
那我分别用的风跟A跟花来做一个对比
这样子的一个创作的安排
等到你慢慢熟悉的时候
你会觉得说哦
那已经变成本能反应了
所有的本能反应是你创作的时候都不用想
就像我之前有个工具书
就是韵脚的数据库
后来的创作基本上已经不需要了
因为有些词汇你已经常常用了
有些画面感的掌握能力已经很强了
脑海中会有个空间感
空间感会带来画面
画面就带词汇
词汇就变成你创作的素材
或者说建筑的材料
你就会自然而然的出现
这个就是一种训练
一种累积
接下来我们分享的是一首抒情慢版的中国风
叫醉赤壁
像这首歌是好几年前的创作了
那没想到近几年里面有个歌词段落确认过
眼神却变成一个话题在流行
就觉得嗯还蛮有趣的
接下来我们分享的是抒情慢版的中国风
这样子一个曲风的风格
它的词义方向是如何的
去跟他结合或者是贴近呢
首先我们看到的是a one
落叶堆积了好几层
而我踩过青春
听见前世是谁在泪雨纷纷
一次缘分结一次绳
我今生还在等一次
就只能有一次的认真
这首歌的创作格式是一韵到底
就是所有的压同一个韵脚
这首歌在创作的当时
其实副歌的第一句是先出来的
确认过眼神一说
觉得诶你人生中要确认很多事情
确认态度
确认爱情确认这么多
那你们确认眼神这个是对的人吗
这个眼神给你的讯息是你要的吗
所以那时候我就先写下确认过眼神
那就搁着也不动了
我一直强调要准备一个小册子
就是记下你突然灵光乍现
天外飞来一笔的一个好句子
不管这个句子长或短
就先记下再说
不要太依赖记忆力啊
也不建议记在手机里面
因为手写的东西有个温度
那通常你在写的时候就已经记忆一遍
而且把累积成一本的时候
变成你个人的纪念品
当初写下确认过眼神的时候
并不是要给林俊杰用的
也不是要写一首歌叫醉赤壁
都不是就搁着
然后在半年后接到一个合作案
这个合作案再找一个线上游戏的一个主题曲
来的时候想说哎确认过眼神
虽然这句词汇其实不那么中国风
但是又觉得好像有发挥的空间
然后就开始想哦
确认过眼神
我遇上对的人
那就写下了
他就开始听他的一个melody
后来我听听JJ的权利之后
诶第三句就跑出来了
我挥剑转身
而鲜血如红唇
红唇是有点性感的感觉
可是是用鲜血那一起挥剑转身哦
定调了
那这个就是为这首歌而创作的一个调性
主轴就很明确了
所以不要觉得说平常的一些琐碎的句子没有用
他到时候会派上用场
就像书到用时方恨少
真的想要写些什么东西的时候
突然就哎呀
很多形容词词汇甚至成语读的都不够多
使不上力
那没有关系
我们有个小册子
那这个小册子呢
就是每个人自己的随身的一个锦囊
一个法宝
接下来第二大段
前朝记忆渡红尘
伤人的不是刀刃
是你转世而来的魂
是不是很武侠风
一再强调关键字会让故事有画面感
而这个画面感会行说出你这首词作品的风格
而且可以定调里面有个词汇
我自己很喜欢那句歌词
是青石板上的月光照进这三层
我一路的跟你轮回声
我对你用情极深
那青石板是以前古代的城池
有没有他在铺在地板上那种天然的岩石板块
那天然的岩石板块走久了
它其实会反光哦
因为它上面会比较亮
人的痕迹啊
马的痕迹把岩石弄得比较油亮
那月光照下的时候
其实会反光照进这个三层
单纯的概念又很具象对称
因为三层其实很硬的
但是用情极深是很软性的
所有的师傅带进门修行
在个人就是这个意思
就是我教你的跟你完全掌握吸收的是两回事哦
好那我们继续分享下去
第二大段的主歌是洛阳城旁的老树根
像回忆般延伸
你问经过的是谁的心跳声
我拿醇酒一坛饮恨
你那千年的眼神是我坠坠坠入赤壁的伤痕
这里面要特别讲解的是坠坠坠入赤壁
因为这首歌叫醉赤壁
那醉醉是喝醉的醉哦
然后第三个醉是坠入的坠掉下来的意思
听觉上是同一个音坠坠坠入
但是视觉上它其实是不同质的
这个其实玩一点文字游戏就很特别
听起来是坠坠坠入
但其实是两个喝醉的醉
一个掉下去的那个坠入
这样子的一个创作也是一种形式
听觉的谐音跟视觉文字的不同
会让人家看到MV的时候有个惊喜哦
原来收音机听到的坠坠坠入也是同样的音
结果一看到MV原来是不一样的字句
这个其实就是一种语法
算是一种
小技巧
接下来分享最后一首叫布拉格广场
这首歌的旋律调性是RMB的
但是呢因为他的作曲的形式很丰富
它里面还有rap说唱的部分
甚至于整个节奏听起来好像还有舞曲的感觉
这首歌相信各位同学在视频上有看到
里面很多奇怪的英文
这一大段的英文不是我写的
他怎么来的呢
demo带的时候就有了
因为当初创作的时候
周同学拿给我的歌
就这一大段的英文
那这一大段的英文是什么呢
有些是没有意义的字句嘛
啊啊福说啊啊说啊啊啊
其实没有意义的
那里面有意义的句子
其实是一种音乐的术语
就是速度跟速度有关的音乐术语
而且是意大利文
这首歌在创作的当下就已经知道未来是蔡同学
也就是蔡依林演唱
然后拿到demo带的时候
就已经知道创作的方向了
因为这是企划导向的一个创作
所有的企划倒像是唱片公司里面
有些歌手是创作型歌手
创作型歌手呢就是词曲都自己创作
但有时候词是别人写
那创作完之后
公司在挑歌
在挑主打歌
接着再做进行所谓的企划包装
这个是创作导向
只是创作的东西
先有再给它包装
那有些是企划导向
企划导向是创作的概念
先有甚至于NV去哪里拍都已经先出来了
然后计划的一些文字关键字会先给你
但是这首歌倒是没有什么关键字
这是我们先原创
但是创作的方向就很明确
虽然没有给关键字或有其他的要求
但是创作的方向就是偏欧式的一种结构
那这种欧式的结构是比较精致的那种欧式
而不是那种战争或粗犷的欧式
所以呢歌词的内容
基本上围绕着城市的景观去发展
然后呢我们先来分享第一段的主歌
琴键上透着光
彩绘的玻璃窗装饰着歌德式教堂
谁谁谁弹一段一段流浪忧伤
之所以把歌词做这样子的一个段落
是因为曲的格式它本来就是长成这样子
所以那时候我填的时候
我想说一段一段就叠音就好了
不要马上换字
因为它太近了
一段一段流浪忧伤好
接下来我们再继续下一行
我顺着琴声方向
看见蔷薇依附在18世纪的油画上
就是很很欧风的感觉
而且18世纪还是油画哦
在旁静静欣赏
在想你的浪漫
再看是否多久都一样
这一段我可要好好的讲解一下
因为音乐的段落限制了我文字的延伸
但是却也因为音乐的段落
让我文字的结构有了特别的布局和安排
怎么说
你看到在旁静静欣赏
在想你这样慢再看是否多久都一样
我用在旁在想在看去呼应下一个歌词的段落
但是在这个字我维持着不换
因为他的段落太近了
你必须要重复的字句去强化记忆
所以我用再盘再想再砍
汉先有曲后有词的文字
最常遇到这种状况
就是音乐的结构
某种程度会限制了你文字的生长
但是这种限制哦
记得换个角度看问题
反而也让我的歌词的结构
有了一种特别的形式哦
这个是拜旋律的段落所赐
如果他旋律的段落不是这样子
断他的节奏不是这样子的一个安排
我的歌词就不会有这样的一个创意
什么创意呢
我用在旁在想在看去呼应欣赏浪漫跟多久
然后最后结尾是都一样
这个就是相辅相成
就是词曲的搭配
所以切记哦
不管旋律的结构长成什么样
我们就是在这个旋律的基础和地基上盖房子
那盖之前你就已经知道这个地基的结构了
它的频数有多大了
所以呢你就尽其可能地利用它的地基
去干你心目中想要的歌词大楼
再来还有一小段咯
我就站在布拉格黄昏的广场
在许愿池投下了希望
那群白鸽背对着夕阳
那画面太美
我不敢看
歌词里面描绘着许愿池
就是投下了希望
后来有人去布拉格旅游
然后他发现布拉格市中心最大的广场
其实是没有许愿池的
呃
有没有许愿者
其实我不知道
因为我写的时候根本没有去过布拉格
就像我写上海1943也没有去过上海一样
而且蔡同学的二名你知道吗
他有拍到许愿池
所以我想说他们是打井的啦
搭景拍的MV
他们也没有去过布拉格
是因为想象中的欧洲
然后在城市的中心都好像有个许愿池
可以投币吗